big data can come from several different
sources
one way to think about it is whether the
data was produced by a human or whether
it was produced by a machine
human generate a lot of data whether we
mean to or not
the first thing that i want to talk
about is intentional data
this is the data that you know you are
creating
for instance if you take photos videos
or record audio or put text on a social
network you know you're doing it
you can also click like if you're on
facebook
when you do web searches a record of the
web pages that you have viewed are
bookmarked
your emails and your text messages your
cell phone calls
if you read an ebook the highlights the
notes in the bookmarks and online
purchases
all of these are kinds of data that do
not exist until the person deliberately
makes them happen
so these are records of human actions
what is interesting is that in addition
to these intentional pieces of
information
there's also metadata metadata is data
about
data you might call this second order
human generated data
the idea is that this is data that
accompanies the things that you do
and you may not be aware of it
interestingly
metadata can be enormous sometimes
larger than the actual piece of data you
created
perhaps metadata is more significant
than the actual data for the big data
world
because it is computer generated and is
already machine readable and searchable
here are a few examples of metadata and
what can be done with it
for instance if you take a picture with
your phone you not only get the picture
you also get what's called the exif data
that stands for exchangeable image file
format and this is the metadata that
comes from a picture on an iphone
aside from the name of the file which
you see at the top left
and that it's 3.1 megabytes and the time
that it was taken near the bottom on the
right side
you can see the gps altitude latitude
longitude and position
or part way up from that you'll even see
the gps image direction
it knows which way you're holding the
camera this is an enormous
amount of information that accompanies
the photo that you get
for instance if you take a picture with
your phone you not only get the picture
you also get what's called the exif data
that stands for exchangeable image file
format and this is the metadata that
comes from a picture on an iphone
aside from the name of the file which
you see at the top left
and that it's 3.1 megabytes and the time
that it was taken
near the bottom on the right side you
can see the gps altitude
latitude longitude and position or part
way up from that
you'll even see the gps image direction
it knows which way you're holding the
camera this is an enormous amount of
information
that accompanies the photo that you get
another example is email metadata
there is a lot of information that
accompanies each email
the four very common pieces are who is
it from who is it going to
did they cc anybody carbon copy anybody
and the time that it was sent
now one really interesting thing about
this that you can do for yourself
is that mit has created a web app called
immersion that allows you to do a quick
analysis of your own social network via
your email account
i am going to show you the immersion
website
it's immersion.media.mit.edu
and what it does is it takes those four
pieces of information about your emails
and it puts together an image of the
network for example
here is the immersion demo with
fictional data
imagine a fictionalized character tony
stark
he has information six years of emails
20 000 emails to 159 collaborators
and what you can see is who was in his
group we have more to travis than
anybody else
it looks like travis is connected with
tabitha and you can change
for instance how things are distributed
over here
the number of notes that show now we
have more and more people showing up
we can make that a little bit smaller
and the strength of the links between
them
what is interesting is that for instance
when you do it to your mailbox
you might be able to find distinct group
that shows for your family for my job
and for people that you socialize with
there are sometimes people who connect
several of those groups at once but the
interesting is that
this is just based on who you sent the
email to who it was from
the ccs the time and the date and that
is how it is able to reconstruct your
own personal social network
the last thing i want to show you is
about twitter
now one of the interesting things about
twitter is that tweets are very small
they are limited to 140 characters
what is interesting about this from a
research point of view
is there is an enormous amount of
metadata that accompanies each tweet
this image here was put together by an
employee at twitter rafi cricorian
the information in the red is the
content of the tweet
that is the stuff that you meant to put
there but look at all this other
information that accompanies it in terms
of whether there was a reply a truncated
version
the author's screen name and url the
location the creation data
the account the number of followers the
time zone
their language whether they have a
verified badge the place
id the url the country the bounding box
the application they sent it and etc
it is an enormous amount of information
the metadata in this
case is several times greater than the
actual content
this is one of the most interesting
things and this is why twitter
in particular is a very rich data set
for people who are doing marketing
research or social connection research
in summary there are all sources of big
data and one of the interesting things
about it is that the metadata in
particular
does not have to be processed it is
already computer readable
it is searchable it is mineable and you
can start to get information about it
immediately to reach your big data
analysis purposes